what is going on everybody welcome back
to the cosmic wonder I'm your host
Warren Thompson and if you love
Spider-Man we have some amazing
Spider-Man news today not actually for
The Amazing Spider-Man character sorry
Andrew Garfield but for Toby Maguire's
Spider-Man character although of course
we are going to be talking about Andrew
Garfield Spider-Man and Tom Hall and
Spider-Man as well in this video but it
looks like Toby Maguire could be coming
back to play Spider-Man once again this
time possibly in his own solo film
giving us a Spider-Man 4. the movie that
we never got that we were supposed to
get if you were unaware Sam Raimi the
legendary director directed the first
three Spider-Man films with Tobey
Maguire however there was supposed to be
a fourth Spider-Man film also with Tobey
Maguire vulture was supposed to be the
main villain of this film however due to
a lot of criticism and hate that
happened with Spider-Man 3 the studio
decided not to make the film and based
off of previous interviews that we've
seen this really hurt Sam Raimi and it
hurt Toby Maguire and it also kind of
put not necessarily a bad taste in Sam
raimi's mouth but it kind of left its
Mark so we never thought we would be
getting the fourth Spider-Man film with
Sam Raimi directing and Toby Maguire
being the Spider-Man however a lot has
changed recently we've had Spider-Man no
way home in which Tobin McGuire of
course came back with Andrew Garfield
and Tom Holland then we got Doctor
Strange 2 Multiverse of Madness in which
Kevin feige asked Sam Raimi to come back
and direct it after they lost the
director Scott Erickson so both synths
have made their return to Marvel and
their debuts in the Marvel Cinematic
Universe and now an actor from the
Spider-Man franchise has stated that he
has heard that Sam Ramey could possibly
be doing Spider-Man 4 with Toby Maguire
he said this in an interview with
comicbook.com which of course we'll go
over in this video and talk about what
Spider-Man 4 could actually be about and
if you're new be sure to subscribe
subscribes you don't miss out on any of
the latest news and if you subscribe and
leave a comment you're automatically
entered in our giveaway for a chance to
win an Xbox series X A PS5 some Marvel
Legends items or some DC items we pick a
winner at the end of each month and the
winner picks one item so comicbook.com
recently did an interview with Thomas
Hayden Church he played Flint Marco AKA
Sandman in Spider-Man 3 and he returned
to play Sandman once again in Spider-Man
no way home and in this recent interview
with comicbook.com he told them that he
would love to appear in another
Spider-Man film and that he's heard
there could be a Spider-Man 4. in the
interview with comicbook.com this is
what he said there's always been some
kind of I've heard rumors that Sam Raimi
was going to do another Spider-Man with
Toby Maguire and if that happens I would
probably campaign to maybe at least do a
cameo now what's really interesting
about this is there's been a lot of
rumors going on after Spider-Man no way
home this isn't the first time that
we've heard somebody talk about
Spider-Man 4. in fact many insiders have
stated that Sony is very interested in
developing a Spider-Man 4 with Toby
Maguire and after Sam Raimi came back to
do Doctor Strange in the Multiverse of
madness he did say that that taste was
out of his mouth and that essentially he
has moved on from the hate that
Spider-Man 3 got and we do know that he
was pretty heartbroken that he didn't
get to do Spider-Man 4 but after
Spider-Man no way home came out Toby
Maguire stated that he would love to
return again as Spider-Man he would love
to do more and I think after Spider-Man
no way home many fans would love to see
Tobey Maguire come back and see a story
that could be about a completely
different part of his Spider-Man's life
a life where he is married to MJ and
possibly even has a daughter May Parker
who eventually goes on in the comics to
become Spider-Girl we actually got to
see May Parker recently Peter B Parker's
child and Spider-Man across the
spider-verse in which we did also see
Tobey Maguire Spider-Man in that movie
as well however the footage used was old
footage from the previous Spider-Man
films so the thought of Toby Maguire
returning for a Spider-Man 4 Along With
Sam Raimi the director of the original
Spider-Man trilogy with Toby Maguire is
super exciting now as far as what it
could be about if they are going to go
with what Spider-Man 4 was originally
going to be about this could be a fight
between Spider-Man and vulture but a
fight in a way that we've never really
seen before we also know quite a bit of
what the plot of this film was actually
going to be and who exactly was going to
be in it and an animation and VFX
designer for the film actually released
test footage of what the fight between
Spider-Man and vulture was supposed to
be like but as far as plot details of
what Spider-Man 4 was supposed to be
about it was supposed to be about Peter
Parker and Mary Jane Watson's
relationship being kind of thrown into
turmoil by the arrival of Peter's new
colleague Felicia Hardy AKA a black cat
who was supposed to be played by Anne
Hathaway while attempting to navigate
his feelings for Felicia Peter must also
battle the vulture a criminal mastermind
who plans to seize control of New York
City's criminal underworld unaware that
the vulture is Adrian tombs John
Malkovich Felicia's adopted father and
Peter's new boss at The Daily Bugle
newspaper Peter accidentally kills tombs
halfway through and Felicia adopts the
identity of voltris to seek revenge for
her father she ends up defeating Peter
but spares his life and moves to Europe
while MJ moves to La after learning that
Peter cheated on her and Peter rage
quits being Spider-Man again now that
was what Spider-Man 4 could have been
obviously due to creative differences
this project never happened and I think
that it was probably a good thing at the
time I'm not sure this is what some fans
would have really liked to see and
according to some of the designers some
VFX designers a lot of people didn't
really see John Malkovich as vulture and
I imagine that Sam Raimi and Tobey
Maguire will want to basically do
something from scratch not completely
from scratch of course I'm sure they'll
keep the continuity the same continuity
with Spider-Man 1-3 again this still
should be a sequel from Spider-Man 3 but
we've already had a vulture in the MCU
technically we still kind of have him if
he's not transferred to the Sony
Universe yet that's still kind of
confusing to us but we've seen vulture
and again we recently saw him in
Spider-Man across the spider-verse but
luckily there are just so many awesome
Spider-Man characters that we could see
Tobey Maguire Spider-Man fight in
Spider-Man 4. plus not to mention the
MCU exists now and it didn't before so a
whole different world literally of
possibilities is now open they could
have a Spider-Man movie that sets place
inside of the MCU especially with
incursions happening right now and the
Multiverse being a huge thing it is
after all the Multiverse Saga there is
just a ton of potential right now for a
fourth Spider-Man film because there are
just so many different ways that they
could go about making this movie they
could have it take place inside of the
MCU in a different universe or they
could simply have it exist in its own
Universe from before the Sony Universe
again keep it the same or they could
technically do both have it be a
different universe and have Peter Parker
be dragged into the MCU because of the
events that are taking place in the MCU
in the Multiverse Saga because of Kang
we have already heard rumors from some
insiders that Toby Maguire is going to
be in secret Wars and he'll be alongside
Hugh Jackman's Wolverine something that
everybody is truly excited to see if it
does indeed happen and today we get a
little bit closer to actually seeing
that take place because we know Hugh
Jackman is returning as Wolverine and if
Toby Maguire is returning a Spider-Man
in which he already did return us
Spider-Man in no way home then the
possibility of Hugh Jackman and Toby
Maguire being together on screen in the
Marvel Cinematic Universe is getting
closer to happening but since Sam Remy
recently took on a Multiverse project
with Multiverse Madness it could
actually work both ways he could dive
into that again or he could simply say
you know what let's just kind of focus
on the world that we created before go
back to that and make a sequel to
Spider-Man 3 in the same universe same
storyline same plot we just get a new
villain get a new story for Spider-Man 4
but keep Peter Parker with MJ maybe
they're a little bit further on in life
obviously since they're both a lot older
than they were when Spider-Man 3 took
place maybe say they're married maybe
say they have may Parker and we take it
from there based off of what we heard in
Spider-Man no way home Toby Maguire of
course is still Spider-Man in fact when
he went through the portal he was
wearing his Spider-Man suit under his
clothes and the way he talked to Andrew
Garfield Spider-Man made it seem like
him and MJ found a way to make it worked
them to be together and him to still be
Spider-Man because we know that that is
a classic struggle for Spider-Man to
balance the relationships that he has so
overall this is great news there are
rumors going around now within the
Spider-Man actor groups that another
Spider-Man is on the way Spider-Man 4
with Sam Raimi and Toby Maguire and
again after no way home came out a lot
of insiders came out and said that Sony
was looking to make this film finally so
fingers crossed this is being discussed
at Sony right now and that it actually
happens and if it does let us know what
you would like to see from it what
stories what villains whatever it is
what would you like to see from it let
us know in the comments down below don't
forget to like the video and subscribe
so you can stay up to date on the latest
news and enter our giveaway you can also
find us on patreon you can check out our
website and our Discord server and you
can follow us on Instagram and Twitter
as always thank you all so much for
watching woof woof
thank you